à l'heure où les réseaux sociaux sans
flamme à la première étincelle et où la
moindre déclaration est prétexte à
polémiquer faire de l'humour à la
télévision librement semble être devenu
presque mission impossible
ces dernières années plusieurs
humoristes ont fait les frais de cette
période particulièrement tendue en se
retrouvant au coeur de scandales pour
des sketches jugé polémique
dernier exemple en date jean marie
bigard ou encore texte qui à cause de
certaines blagues à la télévision ont
perdu propre autre exemple avec les
humoriste kev adams et gad elmaleh qui
lors de la diffusion de leur spectacle
commun sur m6 avait déclenché une vive
polémique à cause d'un sketch jugés
racistes sur deux chinois
et bienvenue dans cet angle vous allez
mal
pourtant cette période de polémique à la
chaîne n'a pas toujours existé en 1987
les français se prennent d'affection
pour les nuls
une troupe d'humoristes composé d'alain
chabat dominique farrugia chantal lauby
et bruno carette qui ose tout et
révolutionne l'humour à la télé sans
aucun filtre
[Musique]
si aujourd'hui ils sont considérés comme
des références en terme d'humour et
amuse toujours autant le public avec
leurs sketches et répliques cultes
ceylan mégawatts selon vous les nuls
pour utile exister aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va revenir sur disquette
dominique on est très contentes sur la
soir que tu vas pour nous éclairer aussi
là dessus et on va voir voilà par
exemple là on va revoir le sketch de
euros royal rabat voilà c'était une
dizaine de fabrique des nues ce sont les
fausses pubs on le salé est l'une des
plus mythiques qui fera sans doute
polémique aujourd'hui ce qu'elle frise
polémique aujourd'hui ou pas vous allez
voir moi je suis pas sûr que celle-ci
moi je pense qu'elle passerait le
regarder
[Musique]
royal à rabat fait rire c'est quand
alain soute la clôture il s'est foulé la
suite nous voit tomber alors alors c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu voilà est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui ça pourrait passer ça moi
je trouve oui parce que le témoin c'est
quand c'est drôle mais voilà où c'est
drôle eh ben ça ça c'est indémodable ça
passe il ya personne n'y trouve rien à
redire c'est quand ces moyens qui
mouraient veut un peu vaseux tiré par
les cheveux que là du coup sa peau ce
pas un seul argument c'est que la
question serait le rebond d'aujourd'hui
et qu'elle ne se posait pas aller
absolument moi c'est pas on est en train
de débattre on a posé la question il a
raison il a réservé un dominique dont il
a totalement raison on ne se pose est
pas là car on à l'époque quand on
écrivait des conneries on les tourne est
directement personne ne nous relisais
pardon et on avait le droit de tout
faire
est-ce qu'on aurait le droit de tout
faire aujourd'hui je ne pense pas assez
juste ça après je suis assez d'accord
avec un truc lui manque c'est l'humour
ah oui quand ça fait rire c'est certain
parce quand ça fait moyens rire ça passe
plus ça passe plus plus d'huîtres ou
alors et je suis désolé mais le demi je
dis monsieur le juge je n'ai pas violé
pas plus que les autres moi ça me fait
rire va essayer de le faire maintenant
que je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
avec toi on pouvait le faire on ne fait
plus bon il ya quand même une police de
la morale qui existait au pays tu as
raison eric quand tu dis à l'époque on
ne pose se posait pas la question
alors bonjour est qu'on voit un autre
sketch est une parodie qui pourrait
faire polémique aujourd'hui dénoncés à
la fausse pub pour le dentifrice clan
gut avec des femmes violées regardez et
raymond tu as donné ton âme à sa passe
pas tu vois je
ok
[Musique]
mais les fraudes et les légumes quel
goût dentifrice au fluor existe aussi à
la menthe et bien on amical beau c'est
beau jeu du monde chez vous est ce que
vous pensez que ça pourrait passer ça
aujourd'hui dîtes-nous tiendra demain il
serait pas passer ça ça serait pas
passée ta je pense à tony clan dinka et
grady ça passe même pas peut-être dans
le film des nuls quand elle dit vous
voulez pas un whisky juste un doigt sa
pince marge infime
ça n'est pas parce que avant tu faisais
un truc comme ça on le regardait on se
marre un et on passe à autre chose
aujourd'hui imaginez vous sur twitter
ont été tout de suite non marc morandini
reprend lautié reprend lautié reprend
faut aller s'excuser de reproduire un
sketch ça ne passera jamais parce que
les gens maintenant ont changé les
mentalités ont changé
l'humour a changé les gens ont changé
d'humour aussi peut-être moi je pense
que ça ce sketch la même des gens
aujourd'hui tout de suite quand ils ont
vu ils ont dû dire à ma [ __ ]
heureusement que ça passe pas et moi
pourtant ça me fait rire héros et leurs
amarres ça me fait rire alors il ya un
autre sketch où on voulait montrer c'est
le sketch c'était le slogan de la sncf à
l'époque c'était à salles nc fc a aussi
regardé que se manifeste et nadja une
paire de chaussures en croco est pas
possible
oui mes chaussures voilà
voilà où les le cirage avec non non je
voudrais la petite pendule plaqué or
l'appui aussi le cadre de marrakech avec
les lumières qui s'allument électricité
autant c'est pas possible non plus relax
oui oui bien sûr je voulais que je
l'amène à la maison c'est possible aussi
oui bien sûr oui et si je te demande en
plus des cacahuètes
oui le costume blanc laqué jolie je te
paie plus tard tu peux me dire que c'est
possible oui bien sûr voilà vers des
faux électeurs la signature voilà et ça
c'est cadeau ça me fait plaisir
comment oui la sncf si possible on
entend les gens rire là les gens ont ri
en écho en regardant le torse donc
jusqu'à deux disques ce qu'est ce qu'a
dit jean michel est totalement vrai si
c'est drôle ça passe moi je n'y a rien
de pire qu'un humoriste qui
s'autocensurent la seule chose qui pose
question aujourd'hui c'est l'autocensure
ans comme l'a dit dominique aujourd'hui
les humoristes poserait se pose la
question mais si tu y vas tu es tu peux
y aller franco
quand on est si tiendront gersende aux
reliques mais vers ça qu'on prend des
accents auront on dit mais il ya
toujours quelqu'un qui s'insurgent
maintenant à dominique bruneau avait
d'une part nos caractères le car est
pardon vous avez raison abou dhabi a
fait penser à lui parce que vous êtes
bien sûr ils parlaient l'arabe
couramment il avait le bon accent le
texte de calgon c'est lui qui l'a est
clean
voilà il était il aidé au maroc et et il
a il avait toutes les qualités pour le
faire
alain chabat tu fais royal rabbin voilà
c'est chacun allait l'appel à ussel feu
démarré
bon voilà bruno carette deux jours il a
fait ce sketch il s'est assis dans le
bureau il était tellement bien maquillée
que j'ai pas reconnu et je me
rappellerai toute ma vie j'ai des
cuisses propres il ya un épicier arabe à
côté alors il ya une autre télé de pub
couvreur c'est avec toi dominique est ce
que tu te rappelles de calgon
malheureusement oui
ouais alors reconnu ne pas savoir de
mais j'aime pas et j'aime pas boire je
verrai alors banon mais regarde parce
que alors celle-ci
regarde bonjour bonjour je suis le
brassin du dessus et mon lave linge est
en panne oui et j'aurais dû utiliser
cargo est là que l est pas drôle y'a pas
y'a pas moi j'avais aujourd'hui qu'ils
prennent risque de te dire mais vous
avez aucune limite 5 était génial soit
sur sa zone et que tu allais dire
gravier oh non j'ai aucune limite serait
ce que moi je m'appelle d'un sketch qui
m'avait fait mari qui est ce qui t max
pète ça aujourd'hui ça passe jamais la
télévision se seraient censurées
obligatoirement y avait il y avait aussi
le tube c'était avec le chat le chat
rachid bank et trouver et aujourd'hui je
suis sûr que mine de rien sur celle-là
on auront dorer les problèmes regarde le
nouveau le chat machine conclu à une
meilleure protection de l'environnement
avec le nouveau le chat machine
il n'y a plus du tout deux fait
d'envolées cible
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oui je j'envie la naïveté de jean michel
et valérie mais ça reste malheureusement
de la naïveté on a combien d'exemples
mal ou non de carrière d'humoriste brisé
censuré lâchés par leur producteur jean
marie bigard il faisait les mêmes
blagues il ya dix ans aujourd'hui ses
blagues vannes l'annulation complète
s'est tournée we take ce bon c'est pas
accès le plus grand des humoristes mais
on vit malheureusement ou heureusement
je sais pas dans une ère de ce qui
s'appelle l'indignation systématique et
communes en l'air c'est à dire que
l'humour n'est plus reçu en tant que tel
derrière l'humour on va chercher un
message raciste un message caché une
attaque envers une communauté envers une
religion envers qui que ce soit donc
cesser on peut plus rigoler simplement
de tout alors les autres que tu vas voir
cette série vous êtes a aussi attaqué
aux chercheurs qui sollicite des dons
pour faire avancer la recherche
une meilleur temps ce venez balle et
barbie
venez voir le voici parti donc avez vous
découvert
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
l'équipe est la science
ce sont d'abord des hommes et des femmes
qui cherchent alors aidez les envoyés
des sous pour mettre dans le considère
dans le contexte il y avait le patron
d'une grande association pour le contre
la sur la recherche contre le cancer qui
s'était fait prendre la main dans le
parc et c'est pour ça qu'on avait
commencé la halle van hees était parti
de là après sur wii alors agathe
évidemment on est gentil on sait très
bien que l'humour de ya 20 ans ne
passerait plus aujourd'hui on parle est
spécifié abandonné c'est nul ça dépasse
tout ce passe aujourd'hui beaucoup sont
morts ce n'est pas nous qui nous
différenciera san humour qui est très
foncé qui est vraiment qui fait rire
tout le monde qui est généreux
franchement c'est pas nous moore qui
souvent basées sur les dix communes et
drôle et vous serez vous oubliez les
émetteurs qui aimait l'humour qui aimait
le sketch qui est celui qui vous destine
le sketch c'est aussi très important
dans le message qui est envoyé à partie
moment où c'est bruno carette chantal
lauby dominique farrugia alain chabat
ces quatre là ne sont pas suspects donc
appartement ils ne sont pas suspects
d'être raciste ou ceci ou cela et bah du
coup le message peut me riglaire est
dépassé
gardiens alors on va jouer pour montrer
dans les nuls éditions il y avait si les
le jt avec des fausses news
pour parodier les infos regard des
grandes manifestations des coiffeurs
nazis vendredi il criait votez le pen y
médecine des progrès on peut avoir été
lobotomisés continuer à mener une vie
normale
et enfin comme disait odeurs la viande
de porc c'est bon quand c'est mort mais
quand ces vivants ça fait du boucan
[Applaudissements]
c'est oui pas bien le cas non je pense
qu'il ya un mot dans le vocabulaire qui
est qui depuis 7-8 ans a complètement
envahi notre notre civilisation
si le mot discrimination à partie mais
ce mot à toutes les sauces ce qui bloque
l'humour
à mon sens ce que pour pour répondre à
valérie s'est pas c'est pas les
humoristes le problème c'est le message
qui passe qui ont créé un problème dans
la société ce qui n'a rien à voir et
aujourd'hui la moe discrimination est
mis à toutes les sauces
la puissance aujourd'hui dos des
associations si ça vous le rappelez
quand même là il ya des centaines
d'associations qui ont un pouvoir
incroyable en france aujourd'hui et qui
peuvent stopper 1ers jeux je continuais
à discriminer les néo nazis
[Applaudissements]
m'arrêterai quand des parents ont de
toute la question comment on fait des
enfants est serrée qu'à aussi à un
sketch assez cru très très drôle même
regardé c'était un papa comment on fait
les bébés papa comment on fait les bébés
papa comment aux philippines
papa c'est quoi ces bouteilles de lait
et bien ça c'est ta mère
ça c'est ma [ __ ]
et voilà comment les enfants jeux peu
compliqué de tout ce qu'ils demandent et
donna larsen vous montrera comment c'est
la diarrhée avec la crème cac 40
désolé c'est drôle encore matin tu es
drôle maintenant oui oui oui alors c'est
la façon dont les gens faire face qui
chante quoi le mogul effectivement là où
je vous rejoins c'est que la caisse de
résonance et pas la même auparavant ses
sketches là pouvait recueillir des
lettres de deux jambes et c'est ce
n'était que du courrier de l'ex qu'on
appelle le courrier téléspectateurs ça
n'existe plus maintenant c'est sur
twitter donc ça une caisse de résonance
plus importante mais libre à nous aussi
de pas prendre en compte cette caisse de
résonance comme ça elle est absurde
alors tu fais twitter après céder
finalement au csa après mûre csa il voit
olala ya quand même eu 4000 personnes
il faut condamne à trois millions roanne
ou non retrouvées alors vrai qu'on voit
c'est qu'on peut voir nos marges
compenser téléspectateurs bien ma
pression va parler d'alain chabat alors
boîtier d'exister massaro prénom à 73%
commission s'était enfin comme ici